yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
[Music]
[Applause]
expressvpn.com
most americans have probably heard of
approximately
10 candidates but the reality was that
hundreds of people filed to run for
president when i filed as an example
like it got absolutely zero notice
because it's just like andrew yang is
running for president it's like who
gives a [ __ ] like
no one knows who that was because it's
like november 2017. um
so the rules around filing are primarily
social is what i'm suggesting
that the actual rules just about anyone
can satisfy but the the real rules
are the um institutional rules the media
rules
the dnc's rules in this case when did
they finally start noticing you when
you're
like oh this guy's actually not messing
around and he's gonna
do something this was another
entrepreneurship thing the dnc set rules
up to make the debates and then i was
like
what's the rule what's the rules like 65
000 donations
all right let's go do that let's go do
that like it was it was a lot of fun on
that level as a campaign because they
would
like set up a bar for you and then you
were like let's go get it i was passing
people
that we knew they wanted in the debate
um so as long as i did that it was like
the old joke about like you know i don't
need to outrun
the bear i just need to run the person
next to me
like as long as i was outrunning someone
that i knew they wanted to keep then
like i i was gonna be all right
that's so funny that's such a great
analogy to describe that because
it is weird for us at home where they're
like
here's the here's like the here's the
varsity
uh and then here's jv oh that jv
guy he got up to varsity and then that
one varsity guy he's down to
freshman basketball
[Music]
andrew this blew up my weekend
there's an outbreak and we have to do an
episode
very very late thursday night uh i get a
text
this is a true story i'm not that to
um out him uh i don't think he'll care
but so so uh ken jong texts me
uh and he's like hey i'm reading the tea
leaves and i think trump has covid
um and he does this literally like an
hour before the announcement comes out
and then the announcement comes out and
then i was like
oh my gosh like he was right
trump has covid uh and now
uh just shaken up a lot of things uh
i mean we we thought the debate was
going to be the news of the week but
then that's been dwarfed by
uh this diagnosis uh and so the the
question is what does this mean
and you know there are a lot of things
it means on many many levels
uh first no one wants anyone to get sick
like having human beings can track the
coronavirus is a terrible thing
uh too many people have lost loved ones
and friends
and family uh so it's just it's terrible
news no matter
like who it is or uh uh who it affects
um this is the president and this is
going to have
big repercussions beyond um
people in his personal life obviously uh
and so the
first big question is how does this
impact the election
and the campaign schedule coming up and
one cannot look at this any other way
but say that this is
terrible terrible news for the trump
campaign
on so many levels number one there's the
messaging component where
it's very very hard to get anyone to
talk about anything but coronavirus when
the candidate literally has the
coronavirus and is under medical care
for that so that's
that's enormously problematic uh number
two
the operations of the campaign
essentially grind to a halt where the
candidate
is no longer doing events uh
and and to be on the operational front
is the campaign manager
now has the chronovirus uh if you are on
this team you're looking around being
like wait a minute like i was in a
meeting with that person not that long
ago
um so it's going to throw the entire uh
the entire staff into disarray or
remote work or some degree of uh
stress and anxiety so so there there's
like a massive massive
uh wrench in the works uh of
of what is essentially like a billion
dollar business
um where you're taking the leadership
team and the candidate who as we know
is uh both the product and
the
the quote unquote ceo
offline so it's going to be a massive
massive problem
and then you also have the fact that the
government of the united states
is is being scrambled
where the president is in the hospital
uh
you're going to be very concerned about
the vice president's schedule because
you're looking around saying like well
shoot like whatever we thought we might
do um
we might want to rethink it and you have
i believe three republican senators
who've all been diagnosed
in part because they were meeting with
white house staff uh
so this christian diagnosed too man
there's a lot of them
yeah well there's there's talk now that
it might uh
stall the supreme court proceedings too
because you might not be able to get a
majority of republican
uh senators so that there are massive
impacts to this
uh you can't overstate it uh
and if you're rooting for
uh for trump to win this is just
terrible news like some people
suggest that oh maybe there'll be some
humanization or sympathy vote or these
other
things i i am struggling to see that
like that that strikes me as like very
much groping for a silver lining
uh if you're if you're on that side um
so
that that's the impact i see from
the election standpoint
right and the government standpoint and
the governance standpoint
if the republicans had and trump had a
message in 2020
it was crone is not a big deal or it'll
be over soon
and troll the libs is kind of what it is
the ribs are
liberals are radical left and they suck
and um make fun of them and
stay away from them be scared of them
whatever it is uh
those messages are very tough to do when
you have coronavirus
as the leader of the free world right
like i think that's the impact to me
um i don't i hesitated
like trying to make too many conclusions
from this because i think there's so
much up in the air
um to me where
would actually maybe be a death knell
for the president maybe um was this
there's a there's a lot of holes in this
timeline to me that are really
frustrating that i would love that
reporters are scrambling at the bottom
of now where
the biting team did not find out from
the trump administration they tested
positive there's a chance the doctors
today where this is saturday
the third when we record this the doctor
said that
we we started um essentially
it's been a 72 hours since he was
diagnosed and if that is the case then
that means he was doing fundraisers
while knowing he had tested positive
recovery without telling anyone and that
to me is really dangerous
and um it seems the wrong way it seems
pretty clear
that he it seems pretty clear that he
attended at least one fundraiser in new
jersey
uh knowing that he was knowing his
father which is so
dark and twisted um
[Music]
and that's frustrating to me because
that's your base you know what i'm
saying like those donors
like like those are your people that's
like us doing that to the yang gang you
know what i'm saying like yo guys
you know we might just infect you all
right or on the flip side if you're a
guest you like show up to support him
and you know you
let's say pay money and travel and
subject yourself to some things and it
turns out that
uh you were putting yourself at risk by
doing so in a way that was
very real and yeah uh
and concrete then yeah that that like
evelyn said she'd be
incredibly angry uh in in that
circumstance
uh if you were supporting someone and
that was the choice that they'd made so
i agree with you the timeline is going
to come out i think journalists are
going to keep digging on this there are
some journalists who are also in the
same room as people who tested positive
and might not have been notified as such
so that they're going to be new
stories and findings throughout i'm sure
more people will end up testing positive
too because it seems like you have
a fairly uh
a fairly clear mini outbreak
going through through this network of
people who are in close quarters quite
often traveling together
work in the white available uh that you
know you don't hear about because
they're not household names so they're
just a lot of human beings that are
within the
um the vicinity that i i believe
are going to be very concerned and some
of them are going to test positive and
so
so we're going to continue to see
stories in part because the way
coronavirus works is that
it's really difficult to track down in
these circumstances where it takes
multiple days to
show symptoms in some cases it takes
some time for even the
for the tests to be able to show results
that's why they are always recommending
these two-week quarantines as like the
gold standard
and a lot of these folks may not uh be
in position where they can quarantine
that long
oh yeah that's um have you ever been
somewhere where there's an outbreak
even if you don't have it it wrecks your
life because you have to quarantine and
you're worried that you're carrying it
even if you don't have symptoms like
this is
super frustrating if you're like if i
knew if this happened to us on the
campaign it would be
like one of the more frustrating it's
it's a
it's a derailment four weeks for an
election right um
the the one thing i will say i just want
to be very very clear look
we don't like donald trump i think what
he's done to
and i think you agree with this angel
what he's done to downplay this virus
and how he's handled the the pandemic
has been a travesty
um and has caused more people to
straight up die
that said humanity first like he's a
human being like i don't
i wish him a speedy recovery i wish his
wife speed recovery all the people
affected to be very clear we don't
you know but we don't we don't wish ill
on anyone you you don't wish uh
you know sickness and and worse on
anyone and i you know i said it's like i
both hope and expect that he'll make a
recovery
um he's certainly going to get the best
care
in the world um so if anyone has a
chance to
come back from this it would be the
president uh so i agree with you
zach that know that like that there is
uh there's no good that comes out of
anyone becoming
sick with a coronavirus right agreed um
so we wish we wish them a speedy
recovery this election is uh
buckle up right like tbd what happened
to me i i don't
i don't think we can say for certain how
this shapes the race um
because there's still a whole bunch of
things on the air so a whole bunch of
things we don't know
and there's a whole bunch of things that
haven't happened yet we don't know how
serious it is
for the president for his staff and
other things i think what it does do is
it
it confirms the judgment of people who
want to treat the coronavirus very very
seriously
and advocate for wearing masks and
social distancing and public health
measures
like that narrative to me is very clear
where
a majority of americans obviously agree
with with the fact that we should be
doing things to try and safeguard each
other's health
uh and and that that that point of view
is being bolstered by
facts by uh events uh
how that impacts the election i'm going
to suggest it it cannot be good for
uh the president that this has consumed
all the news cycles
uh and that no right now he's uh
under uh strict medical care and
walter reed but it's clear that the
coronavirus as a public health crisis
is front and center and will be for the
foreseeable
if he's running on his ability to lead
in a pandemic
um having an outbreak in your own white
house is probably
counterproductive right um so we'll see
look i mean this stuff doesn't tend to
stick to the donald the way it sticks to
other
types of people so um that'll be the fun
part i will say this like having
there are photos from that and obviously
video from that
um from amy um coney barrett the supreme
court nominee the new nominees
event at notre dame university there are
photos from that event where you're just
seeing a whole bunch of people packed
together
with no masks that is to me
utterly ridiculous that you're doing
that in the middle of a global pandemic
right like
the fact that there's no social
distancing or mask wearing whatsoever
and then everybody gets covered there
and there's pictures like politico has a
picture everybody who's been diagnosed
with govind so far
they just shade them in red and it's
like you know
six people already they're senators and
in prominent people the president of
notre dame has it like this is
ridiculous to me so um
i don't know what's gonna happen um i
think we have our predictions and look
yang speaks we'll be covering the whole
way right so um i hope you guys tune in
stay safe
and uh take this very seriously because
uh
it's clear that that leaders who've
tried to advocate for a cautious
approach have been right yeah
so we recorded this on saturday as soon
as we
frankly could get together and talk
about what's happening here we also have
the rest of our episode which we
recorded earlier
um which you guys will enjoy it's also
great it just doesn't talk about the
president getting coveted which just
happened
so enjoy it guys um we'll move on
[Music]
you know at yang speaks we think that
your data
should be yours we have prop 24 on the
ballot in california coming up
but there are things you can do right
now to protect your data and one thing
we recommend
is use a virtual private network which
lets you beam into the internet from
anywhere no one can track
your activity including your isp which
right now often is keeping
track of everything you do expressvpn is
the vpn that we recommend it's not just
us also wired recommends them the verge
recommends them
expressvpn is best of breed for
consumers
who want your online activity to remain
yours and yours alone
go to expressvpn.com yang to get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free
expressvpn.com
take your data back or at least make it
so that it's not
the data broker's data too if you know
what i mean
all right we're back andrew yes we are
back
digesting the first presidential debate
which was
a horror show because of the continuing
sense of agreement from our current
president
where he just devolved before our very
eyes
and no one can convince me or any
reflective person that this was part of
some grand plan or that this was
uh going to be positive for trump um
so despite the unpleasantness of the
situation
on a viewing level i became very
positive where i said well
joe walked in with the lead he's walking
out with in my opinion a slightly bigger
lead i think it's going to depress
turnout
for for some fence sitters uh and so i
became positive about the night despite
the fact that it was
very difficult to watch and bad for
america to see our current president
softly tacitly approve white
supremacists and call into question
mail and voting and a bunch of other
things that are really awful
uh but despite the awfulness i came out
feeling good because
really there were there was only one
major
uh catalyst left in my opinion on the
schedule
which was this debate because let's say
you're down and you and i have been in
this position
zach let's say that voting starts in a
number of weeks
you have a lot of eggs in this basket if
you're down
and uh they did not take advantage at
all
uh and so i feel great because
uh i i think our chances of keeping this
country
uh functioning um went up because if
we can rest control the white house from
trump in november then we give ourselves
a chance
i'm still very concerned about november
the mechanics of voting but
despite the unpleasantness the debate
was a
positive night for the chances of
turning the page so for those who missed
the
presidential debate um you didn't miss
much well i mean you missed i i mean it
happened
so you missed that but it was it was um
i'll quote cnn
so you know we you work for cnn but they
you know i've got my qualms cnn but
generally i really like them um
and so the direct quote from jake
tappers was that this was a hot mess
inside a dumpster fire inside a train
wreck and then dana bash went so far as
and dana i don't think she normally
curses on air she goes that was a [ __ ]
show
and did not didn't like bleep that out
just straight up said it was [ __ ] show
um here's my thought andrew and i i
really want your thoughts on this um
my gut reaction and i was probably yang
gang if you've supported andrew in the
primary
i wonder if you felt this way too i was
heartbroken
it broke my heart because in its weird
own way the debate was why we ran
in like we were trying to prevent this
catastrophic burning of the country
and look that's that's not really on on
joe i think
most of the the shittiness of that
debate was was on donald trump and maybe
i think it could have been moderated
better um it wasn't wallace's best night
but it's a really hard job
um but watching
like this country have to face massive
massive challenges and
two old dudes just bickering poorly like
bickering with like interruptions in
this
it broke my heart because we didn't win
because we weren't able to be there and
make
it more either more of a positive vision
and things like that i thought did you
have any of that
sense andrew maybe it's more of a yang
superfan
perspective but i love your thoughts on
the emotional weight
watching that no it was a very
disheartening
night for all of us uh on that level
where i i tweeted i said i think joe won
but it feels like america lost
it it feels like america lost uh
something
like it it lost some of the last
vestiges of respectability and
institutional trust and it's not just
here in the u.s too
millions of people around the world
watch that debate yeah it was 100
it was 65 million on tv just you know
and then they expected
the final numbers aren't out yet because
they're still telling like online and
digital and [ __ ] but
it's probably somewhere around like 70
80 million and they
the for context the super bowl gets 100
million so this is close
to the super bowl yeah and that's
multiple times high on the dnc debates
for example so this was enormous
it's going to get viewed tens of
millions of additional times digitally
and it was viewed by tens even hundreds
of millions of people
internationally and they all came away
with the same sense that many of us came
away with bizeau no
like that this is awful uh
and it makes you question
our government our institutions
our election processes uh like
yeah it's uh i mean they're talking
about how like kids just couldn't watch
that like
you know run away from the tv or go to
sleep crying or
like there was it was that kind of
experience
uh you know i'm sort of glad that my
kids
uh could not watch because they just
like they're
uh they just have no interest in that
sort of thing like evelyn was watching
and he's just like we're like forget
this and he's like what
went off i did something else you know i
i was uh
in the cnn studio um because uh you know
i was going to comment there after
uh so yeah you're right to feel that way
zach i mean we all feel that way
yeah um so here's the other thing i
think and i think you have a really
interesting perspective on this
is in 2016
donald trump was in my opinion um
but i think it's close to fact at some
point was the master of messaging
and kind of always has been in his own
way but when he was as a politician he
was a master of messaging so much so
like you and i we combed over
the republican primary debates like
watching this guy because he was
exceptional at this like shitty reality
tv format of getting himself the
attention
um and in 2016 i'll never forget the
first
the first debate one they asked
everybody like hey will you support
raise your hand if you support the
nominee so first question out of the
bait and he refused to raise his hand
just because he wanted the microphone
he's like i'm going to win anyway it
doesn't matter
but then megyn kelly first question
fires adam i remember he's like hey
you've called women terrible things
misogynistic you've called them pigs and
he interrupts and goes only rosie
o'donnell
joke defuse the bomb she keeps attacking
him and he goes look
so i'm paraphrasing he says essentially
this country is too politically correct
and we don't have enough time because
we're losing we're losing to china we're
losing new mexico
and if i'm president we will win we will
start winning again i'm going to make
america great again
and that to me is someone throws
[ __ ] at you you
punt it away you slap away the nonsense
deflect the question and go right back
to message and his message was we need
to start winning
make america great again we're going to
build the wall whatever and i don't say
you have to love the message i mean half
the country hated it
but half the country loved it because
it's very consistent
and principled in that debate andrew he
had
in my opinion no message he was all over
the place so i'm i don't know thoughts
on the way like way trump is handling
2020 like this makes no sense to me like
he's the master
the master messenger and he's got
nothing nothing
um and maybe because his old message is
done what do you think
the same thing happened when he was
asked about his agenda for the second
term he has no agenda he has no vision
he has nothing
uh to go to and and so you're right zach
it's very very different from 2016 where
he would hammer certain points
and messages in a very visceral and
consistent way
this time it was like what joe's
academic record like like there's some
stuff where it's like everyone's like
what are you talking about
uh you know like that he was all over
the place and he doesn't have anything
uh to present to folks even the folks
that are inclined to support him and are
like looking for a reason to vote for
him i think a lot of them are going to
be like
what am i what am i signing up for again
like that there's like a there's a
significant part of me that thinks that
he
um he's just not enjoying himself
anymore because he he thrives on
attention which he's getting um but but
he thrives on
approval and he senses that the approval
is diminishing
quick and it's making him aggrieved it's
making him
uh even smaller and pettier uh and
so he doesn't have it within him to
present a vision he doesn't have
uh and so right now he's just trying to
set the house on fire
and uh you know and that's just
unappealing
like even if you're again somewhat
inclined or aligned you're like
this person you're trying to support
this person this person isn't even the
person i voted for four years ago you
know it's like
it's like at least it doesn't look like
it and
i will say like obama had a change from
28 2008 to 2012
i recall like 2008 was hope and change
and 2012 was a little i mean paul ryan
said this is fear and blame like as a
joke but realistically he was like
poor versus rich like mitt romney's a
rich [ __ ] and i'm a man of the people
it was very
it was it was a different strategy but
it was a strategy
in this case we're just i think they're
trying to do the radical left thing
but that doesn't stick on biden because
he's not he's a moderate he's i mean
fundamentally never has been
um i don't know man um
do you let me let me ask you this i
think this is um
a really interesting takeaway so i think
you your
your analysis of the impact of the
election was like look and you talked
about with this
this with david axelrod like biden needs
to just
hold serve like not not implode look
competent
and as long as trump doesn't get any
crazy home runs or outlandish
um like things that change the narrative
that's going to be good for him still
agree with that like where
um your take away from the impact is is
that still
you still think biden's got the inside
lane to pull this thing out
yeah i do no up by nine points in uh
pennsylvania according to abc
uh competitive in texas he's competitive
in
iowa ohio places that hillary lost by
eight or nine points
um this up in the money
uh relative to trump which is staggering
given that trump
started out with a nine figure head
start um
so things are very very positive by the
numbers really the question is
how quickly and reliably the votes get
tallied when
people are able to project certain swing
states because it's hard to project a
state if you have millions of
outstanding mail-in votes
you know unless the margin of victory is
so significant and
these media organizations do not want to
get it wrong so you can't be like
well our statistician says there's like
a pretty
high chance that he won michigan it's
like oh you probably have to wait for
the vote count
so uh so unless we get some great
results from some swing states quickly
like we might be waiting for a while
but if you were to magically be able to
vote every uh
to count everyone's votes i think joe
wins this thing
uh cleanly if the vote were held today
and the vote is kind of being held today
in some places because some people can
vote early
and the other thing is hey make sure you
register to vote
uh send your ballot uh get a voting plan
go to iwillvote.com
uh because you should vote or if you're
listening to this just please vote
i got mine today it came in the mail or
yesterday i'm gonna do it today
um the it was at the end of it you get a
closing statement it was telling joe
biden's
closing statement which i thought was
awesome he said vote doesn't matter who
you vote for just freaking vote and
trump's
literally was essentially essentially
don't vote like mail in ballots or
disaster
don't forget about um here so let me let
me challenge you on one thing
so and as a numbers guy so i um
spent an hour yesterday combing over 538
um polls i like them because they
aggregate a lot of things and then make
a prediction it's very
i don't think nate silver and the team
are perfect nobody is but i think they
do a very good job they were the closest
they were right they weren't close to
right but they said like
78 76 chance
of clinton winning last time and that
was the lowest anybody gave her um
so i'm looking at the state by state
polls
um so trump wins ohio michigan wisconsin
pennsylvania
um iowa a number of midwest states which
biden is either a toss-up or leading in
right now
but for exa what what freaks me out i
love your thoughts is
in 2016 nate like the list of polls a
polling average saw that hillary clinton
was winning pennsylvania
somewhere between three and nine points
by somewhere in that range and
realistically five to eight was like the
the median there
and she lost that state pretty handedly
like she didn't that wasn't like a
michigan wisconsin was like 100 000
votes or
you know a very small like she got
crushed and bited not crushed but she
lost
it was decisively a percent or two um
biden according to these polls that
average is about the same
like it's saying biden somewhere a
little higher but not a lot higher
um five to nine is what the range is
right now i'm seeing
what are your thoughts on like the polls
being that wrong
again to me it seems like a turnout game
like what are you what are your thoughts
on
what you're seeing in the numbers versus
what we saw in the numbers in 2016.
i think that joe uh is fundamentally
a less unlikable candidate than hillary
was i think that there
that there was like a skew from that
factor
uh that people talk about the shy trump
voter maybe in my opinion
uh this time it's pretty fully baked
like
there were a lot of folks last time who
uh were thinking like oh yeah i'm like
you know vote for trump and
i'm gonna do this thing like i feel like
most of the people who
uh who voted for trump last time are you
know
like are very openly voting for trump
this time there isn't like this massive
block of voters who are gonna
run in and uh vote for him this time the
same way
i think uh people just didn't like
hillary very much you know like
joe using pennsylvania as an example
joe's from scranton
he runs his campaign from like you know
like miles away uh i think he wins pa
you know in a way like just just if you
look at it from a binary
like is he going to perform better than
hillary in a lot of these places
yeah i think he will um and i think
trump's weaker
and i think a lot of people who voted
for trump last time as an
anti-institutional
vote are are just like you know what
that did not
work out the way i i was kind of hoping
for uh
so i'm very much on the um
this lead is real joe is going to win
paige um and it's not just the numbers
it's the fact that joe and hillary are
different candidates
trump 2016 and trump 2020 are different
candidates
uh you know and circumstances are very
different
you know we talk a lot about the people
that voted for trump never wanted to
talk about it
i also think that's whatever kids talk
about that there's a
healthy amount of people who consider
himself democrats and progressive
and supporter of the feminist movement
and other and other things
that didn't like hillary clinton and
didn't want to talk about it
and i would consider myself one of them
i could not stand hillary clinton but i
i support like a badass female like
being in leadership in the united states
of america you know what i'm saying i
didn't
so i wasn't like leading with that with
friends or publicly or anything of that
sort
um so i do i do think there's some sort
of larger trend
there's also a pandemic nothing makes
you yearn for a competent government
like a global pandemic
is what i said so you know i mean that
that's that's a very different
situation yeah um
i am hopeful um but please vote um
please please please all right i want to
quickly touch on um
your thoughts on the new supreme court
nominee
from the donald uh her name is amy coney
barrett um
thoughts on her i have some but i'm way
more curious than yours
if um in terms of how what type of
justice should be how this will play out
anything there i think that the
republicans are going to be
to succeed in uh this hurry up
confirmation which i'm going to suggest
is
is yet another reason why americans are
looking up saying wow
like you know our government uh
really at this point is just nakedly
partisan and political
uh and has double standards for
everything where it's like the same
group that was like oh
year before election don't do it now
it's like what we've got five weeks like
let's do it
and and the the ordinary length of time
of our confirmation
process is over two months you know so
it's like if you could you
you could imagine a world where a
republican stands up and says you know
what guys we don't really don't have
enough time
to do this uh like in the time frame
properly like you know this is a very
serious thing of course not like nothing
[Laughter]
and then you have the stimulus you know
it's like we we can get this thing done
in like record time but
you know it's like hey millions of
americans hurting it's like yeah
let's just like uh it's like wait until
the other side comes to us on that one
um so it's
it's clear what we're all seeing here uh
to me the silver lining is that i
believe we should go on a
supreme court modernization drive that
is long overdue
uh 18-year term limits increase the
number of justices from nine which is
not in the constitution it's just
statutory
uh is a law written in 1869 there is
nothing stopping
the senate or congress i'm saying you
know what
there's nothing magic about nine you
know it's been higher it's been lower
let's just like let it float uh and then
have some appointments
um that actually map to politics just
say
you get a new appointment every two
years you win an election you get two
justices
and then we know what's happening
instead of having it so that
obama appoints one justice in eight
years and trump
appoints three in three and a half years
because of luck of the expiration date i
mean like it like does that
does that strike anyone as you know fair
rational i mean like
that's the kind of thing that gets
people very very angry on both sides
um so it ought to be bipartisan that you
smooth it out you make it more
predictable
more modern more efficient too because
you know
if you have a higher number of justices
you can actually
rotate justices in a particular way and
hear cases
um uh more regularly
um so so there are a lot of advantages
and other district courts do that
it's like you know you you have a number
of justices you don't need them all
for something i mean theoretically like
you know uh
there's actually something not optimal
about the cult of personality that
arises
among supreme court justices right now
where if you look up
like could anyone name the
judges on the second circuit court of
appeals which is a very powerful court
no if you have like really good
institutions you don't need to freaking
know
like the all the judge's names and their
bios and the robes
they should be a cog in a relatively
good working machine right they
shouldn't have the ability to
derail things right i loved rbg too but
this is not
the way it's not like uh you know that
like oh you've got your heroes and
i've got my heroes and like i hate your
heroes and like like that that's not
great for anybody you know let's just
get like a a court that
functions the way other institutions do
um
and also to me like it is ridiculous to
be planning a flag and being like this
justice is going to determine law for
decades
like like if you were running any
organization you'd be like you don't
know what i want to do i want to set a
rule
that's going to apply to people 25 years
from now when i have no idea
what is going on like at that time
you know i mean it's like no one should
be taking pride in that no one should be
like
this thing will stand for like 30 years
ever exactly the same
yeah like like that i mean that's not
um that's not good governance uh so
so i think she's gonna get confirmed uh
and i hope that we re-examine the way
this institution works
yeah um i'm i'm so
fascinated by this part so that trump
came at um
and then fox news and the republicans
are coming at the democrats saying and
he said and trump went out biden on this
on the debate stage said
you're going to pack the court you're
going to pack the supreme court which
means we're going to add more and more
maybe you know if you win the senate if
biden wins and they win the senate they
would put a whole bunch of justices on
there that are all democrats yeah so my
perspective is
is not necessarily joe's perspective joe
did the right thing where he just said
look
let the people decide yeah you know and
and that's the right answer is the right
principle
um you know what i'm suggesting would
also let the people decide by the way
because if you win an election and right
now
like you know you don't get quote
unquote lucky and no one expires like
like during your term then
the people's vote did not count you know
and that's part of it too is that
um you want to translate popular will to
what happens on the court
then you would have regular appointments
and rotations you know so
in like republicans being like people
have decided the election it's like well
if you really care what the people
decide
then you should make it so that it's
regular so that if they decide something
in 2020 then
you know the people are hurt it's
reflected in 2020 yeah
yeah so so so joe's answer on the
principle is correct it's like let the
people decide which means we should have
regular appointments and and some kind
of rotation
i i guess i was saying i think it's
funny or just interesting that
him and then kamala got pressed on this
question too will you pack the courts
you got pressed on at cnn right after
the debate
both of them wouldn't touch that
question with a 20-foot pole and i
believe it's because
they know or their consultants know i've
been have told them they know that
um most people care a lot about so
like the supreme court it's the number
one thing they care about 21 of
americans
is the most important issue on about
which is the biggest of any issue
they know that they're going to attract
a lot of
moderates independents and conservatives
over their camp and saying they're going
to pack the court
would turn them off and the progressive
left the far left and the moderate left
are probably going to vote for them
anyway so might as well not touch it you
think that's their calculus that's what
it seems like to me and i think it makes
sense as much as it kind of sucks to
hear them like just dodge questions
yeah i think that's right i think your
your instincts are right
it could be that they genuinely don't
want to change it too i mean joe has
that
history of having a very high respect
for institutions
uh because he's been part of the senate
for so long um
so it could be just genuinely they don't
like the idea i mean that that's
something
uh that a lot of people feel um one of
the things when we were running we used
to always
you know if there's an issue like this
like andrew what do you honestly feel
and then we would decide
the political ramifications of you being
too honest if you will right um but most
of the time
and you had to like if there's stuff
like hey just don't talk about it if you
can like you'd give it as close as an
honest answer as you could and like
next question please i think there's
stuff that like and i get it like
it's a soundbite world if they get you
saying something that like doesn't sound
good in 10 seconds
it can crush you you know um when in
reality even if it's a right right or
wrong thing you're trying to
fight for the bigger picture so um
anyway
always curious about that um
okay we've got um a couple housekeeping
things before we get to the guest
um we did a caption contest andrew did
you ever see this photo
oh my gosh i have not seen uh the winner
who won
all right i'm gonna say this um yang
gang you know
i love you um dearly andrew loves you
dearly
but yells captions were um were pretty
bad
they were pretty pretty terrible um like
my team we were having fun looking they
were oh not funny
so like you're gonna read this caption
and be like okay that's fine be like
that one like yeah
that one and trust me we read them all
this one
um but um this is kind of a hilarious
caption um so the picture is of andrew
eating
a few it's of you eating a chicken wing
mid conversation with a supporter
and i'm like awkward i don't know i'm
checking my phone in the background or
behind it which i remember this
conversation
and i remember these moments on the
campaign andrew because
you never let food get in the way of
conversations with supporters
you know what i'm saying like you would
eat talking to very important people all
the time which i love which actually
i didn't i didn't love at the time i
didn't think it was the most
presidential move but it was also kind
of
very honest and hilarious at times man's
got to eat yeah continue
to eat so winning caption was a guy
named joe hagg
at jmfh68 on instagram
you've won your caption was andrew yang
bites a rubber chicken wing as organizer
explains the food was a decoration which
i thought was kind of funny
and pretty good
compared to the other stuff like the
fact that i chuckled on that thank you
joe
uh was a win because a lot of them are
not that great
there was something funny it does look
like i might be eating a rubber chicken
in that photo
um i appreciate it joe but the important
thing joe is that you just won
an incredible uh an unagi electric
scooter that's gonna change your life so
let's get in that scooter
it will change your life makes me happy
please don't ignore your dms
over the next it's called a week or so
um or
i'm gonna have to find another another i
don't know someone else to give it to
you
um and i'll guess what but so make sure
it's you joe we're gonna give away one
more
i'm not sure how we won't do another
caption contest i was a little
disappointed i love you all
just it wasn't that funny and as a very
funny person myself just let me tell you
i know funny it wasn't funny um i'm just
kidding
i'm not funny i don't know i don't tell
you um but we're gonna get we'll do
something creative
um because these scooters are awesome
and um i'm gonna beg ynagi for more or
maybe we'll just buy them ourselves
because i love
maybe people want money maybe we should
give away money if we're gonna spend it
but anyway i love these scooters they're
freaking awesome i want you guys to
enjoy them
um so look um
we've got um a pretty awesome guest
today
andrew i'll let you introduce him
because he's actually a friend you've
now become friends
um
they met during the campaign um online
and we have some friends in common
it's joel mchale from community
from talk soup from that
quarantine defining show tiger king
uh from the darkest timeline podcast
with ken jong who was our very first
guest
when we launched yang speaks so joel's a
fascinating guy
because he says had a really interesting
career uh
great perspective family man um
yeah i enjoyed the conversation a great
deal i hope you do too joel mchale
joel mchale you know what um we always
like we schedule we have to email the
actors or their
producers or agents and so we're
emailing joel and every time he was
immediately responsive and so freaking
excited i love this guy because
sometimes these celebrities can be like
either quiet or kind of [ __ ] in the
background joel is not he's the real
deal what you see is what you get
um so you're going to love the episode
tune in joel mchale
[Music]
when i was running for president one
thing i did was drink
a lot of water green tea
more water and now people are coming up
with better ways to keep yourself
hydrated
one of the innovators in this space is
liquid iv
it's the fastest most efficient way to
stay hydrated i'm
32 years old if i have a drink of
alcohol i have them hung over liquid iv
freaking works swear to god i would just
pout i'm just pound one before i go to
bed throw it in a glass of water
you have a serving and it's as much
hydration as two to three bottles of
water how the heck does that work
liquid iv is available everywhere but
you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code yang
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order
if you use the promo code yang
liquidiv.com
get better hydration today at
liquidity.com
promo code yang and you'll thank us
because you'll feel
like your body's getting what it needs
[Music]
[Applause]
i am thrilled to welcome to yang speaks
actor producer host
comedian the other half of the darkest
timeline
and one of the the most influential
figures of the quarantine because
he hosted that tiger kick special on on
netflix
joel mchale welcome joel it's great to
connect
wow i thank you for having me and
i'm guaranteeing i will be the least
intelligent person you've ever had on
your show
uh you know it's a it's a high or low
bar depending upon how you look at it
but i'm sure you're wrong
because we've had at least one person on
here who who go who
who will go nameless dr ken jong
here he is there he is right there
i keep one of his finest movie posters
in my house that's ken
uh for the uh all about steve
um movie that won numerous razzies
and so yeah it's it's i i wish i had
been in it but you know since
do you often have movie posters with
your just your friends in them
so uh so yeah ken ken was the the first
guest on the
the pod uh he and i connected during the
campaign
um and you guys have been co-hosting
this podcast
very happily and successfully uh
appreciate you coming on
i was looking into some of your your
background in work and i gotta say joel
i feel like
uh like you might be one of the bigger
jocks in hollywood at least the ones
that
that
i encounter or in comedy because i feel
like most of the comedians i know are
not what you'd call
fit
[Laughter]
whereas whereas you were actually this
blew my mind you were like a walk on on
a freaking d1
college football team uh and like that
to me is
bananas that's like some freaking stuff
out of
like rudy notre dame or like the movies
or whatnot
yeah well i wasn't good uh i was more of
a mascot
and i the guys but i don't know why i
did it i
so i only played one year of high school
football
i loved it uh but then i was after that
i was like i want to be an
actor and i ran to the theater and
also i loved playing basketball
and baseball and tennis i love
i've just i'm like a golden retriever
that if you throw a ball at me
i'm gonna run after it and pick it up
and throw it at something that's just
my nature and i was recruited to
row like uh like crew which is it which
is itself nuts
so anyone who went to a college where
where there was a crew team
there were all of these tall ripped
dudes who always hung out together it's
like
like you couldn't separate them they
always moved in like groups of four or
five
um the crew guys and and uh i feel like
you're also anomalously tall
um for like a media type you're what six
three
i'm six four six four so we got
recruited for rowing and then you wound
up doing something easy like football
i got into i left rowing
because i got into a scuttle or kind of
a half fist fight
me and this other freshman with the
senior rowing
team of 12 people which is not
a smart fight you ever want to get into
because the odd
the odds are not in the favor of the two
people
unless you're iron man and um they had
all these crazy rituals because nobody
watches crew races anymore except for
the olympics so
if you made the freshman boat they would
shave your head and shave your eyebrows
and then put that hair into a pillow
which then went into a display case of
hair pillows through the ages of the
university of washington
and uh so i it didn't like
and the coach did not come like the we
had been slapped around
and the coach of the crew was just like
hey well yeah that's how it goes and i'm
like
i'm out of here and i do all these
football players and they're like you
should come out and play football
and that was the beginning of a two-year
uh terrifying and wonderful and
fun and i look back on it
with such uh fondness because i re that
is where i learned how to work hard
uh for the first time in my life well
i mean uh d1 athletes they do work hard
like they have you practicing at the
crack of dawn and the rest of it
it takes over a lot of your college
career and so the fact that you pivoted
from rowing and football
to theater and acting and comedy blew my
mind it's like that that seems like a
pretty
dramatic shift the most respect i got
from the players
was on skit night and uh
because i nailed the skits and they
after that like the players who would
not pay attention to me
would walk up and like we would do like
we would act out the sketch again and i
was just like oh i should probably take
a cue
from this that this is how i uh
this is how i'm successful here on this
team is by acting
stuff out but the two guys ahead of me
were
i am an okay athlete these guys were
real athletes and they were they all
went they went to the nfl
and were did well i would have been
uh broken in half uh but like a
paper airplane uh caught in a
like a live wire so it would just caught
flint so i i
like people like you must be really good
i'm like i was fine and i survived but
it was those guys were truly like you
could see
you could just see you know when you see
those guys move it's just
it's otherworldly well just the fact you
hung with them man it's super impressive
uh and when someone gets to your level i
think a lot of people wonder
what your start looked like in comedy
uh in show business uh what like the
origin story looked like because i can
imagine
that being a that's a really tough time
for just about anyone
uh starting out like what what was that
arc like for you
and were was your family down with it
the whole time were they like oh yeah
joel was always going to
no i think uh most of your friends look
at
you like your little nuts uh and they
also i think they think it's a hobby
and especially when you're younger but
then the more serious
one starts getting they get a little
more like are you out of your mind
uh i started literally in haddonfield
new jersey
i did a play the play version
of the disney ride it's a small world
and i always just thought it was so fun
and my parents even said yeah when you
got on stage you seemed
perfectly comfortable and and i was like
yeah i love it
and so i just was in like little plays
and then by seventh grade
i was like this is what i'm gonna do for
the rest of my life
that's what i just wow and wow uh so it
was
because i was such a bad student uh i'm
dyslexic
and adhd and i'm sure
a thousand other things that have
something to do with processing
and so i was terrible in school i
couldn't spell
for [ __ ] i can't even spell [ __ ] s-h-o-t
see and uh i
just love that was my that was my escape
and i
joined this theater group where we
we did plays together we put them on
together
and we were improvisers uh and i
eventually joined this
improvising theater in seattle called
unexpected productions where
i was on stage every single day
practically i think it was like two one
to two days a week
maybe where we weren't performing and
that was that's where i learned
kind of the just that's where i trained
basically and
so there was so much stage time and i
knew that i
needed to eventually get to los angeles
but like my
my wife god bless her for you know being
interested in me i was i had
no job and her family was like
he just uses her because she has a oh no
yeah she has a car and he she drives
them around
and uh they and then i got a job
on local television in seattle which was
this very strange
amazing show called almost live it was a
full-on produced uh sketch comedy show
that was on the
nbc affiliate there's nothing it was a
local show
and uh so it was very popular i
somehow got on that and i
i went from that is a dead that is the
deadbeat that's
my wife sarah he's like that's the
deadbeat that sarah's marrying
to well look at you you're on tv
it was like that it was great
or horrible and um
that that was so that again was a great
training ground because
i can't read a teleprompter i'm much
better at it now
but they had these teleprompter just be
like i don't know what that is and i was
in a sheer panic when these shows were
live
and i can't read and so i i was able to
screw up
a lot on this show and so i'll ever be
thankful
to this guy named john keister and bill
stayton who hired me
and um boy i'm really and then i left
the show because i went to graduate
school for acting because i was like i
need to become a better actor before
i go to los angeles and um
and so i got really again i got into
this graduate school because i
literally got to know other graduate
schools you i applied to every one of
them i got into one
and so uh i i spent three years
just acting and acting and acting and i
was again at a great training and
finally at the age of 29 i moved to la
and again all my friends thought i was
crazy
so that's my that's a long way boring
explanation of how it all kind of
started or how i when i am you know when
i landed here
in los angeles and i was very surprised
it was like january 15th and it was 70
degrees and sunny
and i was like what's happening so there
there's
that's that's how that's how we ended up
in l.a so sarah
so sarah you were dating it sounds like
uh shortly after you graduated
and then our parents are down on you and
then her parents are like oh he's
actually pretty good on tv
uh and so were you married by the time
you arrived in l.a
oh yeah i met my wife in november
of 93 when you were a sixth grader
and um we married
i was 18. i'm married
yeah there you go so i was i was like 21
and i married
her when i was i married in 96.
uh and we didn't we didn't mess around
so we were
married four years before we even moved
here and
so we just celebrated 24 years yeah
uh because we were in 96 which is 20
yeah 24
years 24 years is that right so um
and yeah i don't know what i would have
done without her she's you know the
greatest
thing i've ever that's ever come into my
life sorry kids
and so yeah i dr i i did say before i
married i was like you have to live
in l.a or los angeles i mean los angeles
or new york at some point
uh we have to try have to try and
i gave myself a five year i said just
five years
and if that doesn't if it does if
something's not happening for real in
five years then we'll go back to seattle
and i'll
i'll get a job in local radio doing
weather and traffic
probably so that's that's that was the
plan
and my i dragged my poor wife down here
and and now we're
we've been here for 20 years it's very
weird and we we
it's like we we know you know it takes a
long time to put roots down anywhere
and then all of a sudden you have them
it's very strange and wonderful
i love hearing about how people became
who they are particularly in creative
fields joel because it's
such a brutal process it's soul crushing
and the fact that someone comes through
it and
maintains like a degree of um like
perspective or integrity in the rest of
it i mean it like it it's wild it can
turn you into something
else you start to mistrust people too in
in your own way so in your case it's
really interesting because you had
uh like uh you know by the time you
showed up in l.a you were married which
strikes me as somewhat unusual like
like most of the people i know who moved
to la for the industry or were like
totally single
that they showed up they showed up and
it's like half the reason they were
there it seemed like uh
yeah and uh no i i remember howard stern
he interviewed me right before i did
the white horse uh white house
correspondents dinner thanks for
mentioning that
joel um and he was like do you feel like
you know you became famous you feel like
you missed out on you know just
playing the field and i was like i am so
happy
that i had someone to go home to and to
like bounce things off of it was like a
refuge
so i know that sounds so there's so many
people that are either going like that's
so sweet
or that's yes but it really was like i
don't know what i i probably would have
just
died if i didn't have her so
i so it was so yeah she was
incredibly and continues to be because
we raise our children
incredibly important i literally have
those weird fantasy
dreams where i'm like well if one of us
for some reason in some weird world had
to die
i'd be like oh i would have to go
because she
uh she holds the entire aircraft carrier
of our lives
up and keeps it going so oh don't worry
my wife and i have the same conversation
that
uh among the four of us like i am the
most expendable
where you have you ever heard the two
boys it's like well clearly the boys
aren't going anywhere and so between me
and evelyn like i i'd be the first i
think if you ask the kids they would say
the same thing they'd be like oh
yeah no no go ahead yeah leave now
go ahead and so so you referenced before
that you were you're dyslexic
um which it sounds like you discovered a
little bit later in in life
because of being a parent and when
you're a parent you learn a lot about
yourself one of my boys
is autistic and i've learned a lot from
that
so one thing you've probably heard at
some point over the last number of years
but
a highly highly disproportionate number
of entrepreneurs
are dyslexic where 35
of business owners are dyslexic some
ridiculously high percentage
uh they did a random survey of
millionaires
and it was a similarly high percentage
like 40 of them were dyslexic
and i worked for a ceo who
was dyslexic uh and he was so brilliant
in all these other
ways and when i talked to him a little
bit about his
background what he said was like as a
kid
let's say reading's not your strength uh
and so you adapt and in his case he
ended up just paying a lot more
attention to other people you end up
getting resources for
getting your schoolwork done from other
people from
you know like just you you find ways
around the problem
or like that like leads you to
to become someone who then in let's say
a business context
like you see a problem and then you're
like all right let me just find a way
around that it's like i can't just sit
there and do the homework well you know
i'll figure some other way to make this
happen
exactly what i would do and i always
thought
the system of school is something that i
can figure out so
when i began freshman year of high
school i literally had a
one four great average and
my mom was like are you even going to
class
and i was like through cheating and
through
all sorts of little different ways by
the end of
high school i was getting a 4.0
and i i was averaging i think my
grade point average out of high school
was like three four five three point
four so i was like
all right figured it out and that's what
i kind of like with the
entertainment business same thing where
i'm like how do i get into this crazy
business that's really difficult to get
into and so yeah i
do i did yeah i definitely did what they
said i would have rather
you know started a company where i made
hundreds of millions of dollars and
i could build spaceships and go to mars
or something but no
i'm kidding but no you're you're right
and i also have
a son who is autistic and uh and so
teaching
him is really interesting and uh
and he but he's game for it which is
great
well good for you both i mean i i find
trying to teach
the my the my uh autistics on
it's really difficult because i mean i
can't tell you how grateful i am to
teachers
or service providers who spend time with
him because i feel like
you just have to be so generous of
spirit when
like a kid is not
uh not a natural learner or not really
much of a listener
which is the case with my kid where you
know you could just be
saying something and then his attention
will wander off and even as his parent
like it gets frustrating you're like
come on you know like if you're trying
to like convey this thing to you and
uh you know that you'll your mind will
just completely drift to something
or i'll be saying something and then
he'll uh he'll
respond to me in a way that says like i
dad i was not listening to anything you
were saying for the last several minutes
[Laughter]
you know it was like what am i doing and
then you see parents do the same thing
like they take it like chips they take
it better than i do a lot of the time
did you ever go like i ran for president
and a bunch of people listen to me
that's i always
i would yeah i always bring i always
bring up jokingly i'll be like
hey you know i did you know host the
espys so maybe
you could spend the next two minutes
looking at this
uh you know this physics question i
never bust out the presidential card
because
i have to say my kids really had no clue
what the heck dad was doing
uh and still i still don't think they
really understand what the heck was
going on
because um better do one of them in a
few years
that would be great then they'd be old
enough to get it but one of them was
very young and the other one's just
extra clueless and so
like you'd think that like gets to be
like hey dad's running for president
the the major upside for my kids was the
bus
like i think the only thing that they'll
remember is that there was a giant bus
with daddy's face on it and we we carted
them around
iowa on it and it had uh big tv screens
and video games inside and we got like
uh
like one of those old nintendo play um
you know like 64's so that they could
screw around on the
bus uh and be entertained so that that
was like the high point i think
uh for them if you ask you know other
than that they still have no idea what i
do for a living even now it's like daddy
disappears into his room for a while
they always like they tease me
they'll watch an episode of community
and then go hey that was a really good
episode
except for your acting and i'll be like
oh
thanks a lot and so
uh yeah they they're always constantly
they're like dad
hey it's so great that you were you did
that community or the soup but when do
you think you'll be relevant again do
you think you'll ever be relevant again
thanks i was like at least i realized
i've taught them well i've taught them
sarcasm hopefully it's sarcasm uh
but yeah no they i in this age of zoom
i don't i it makes me i'm
driven to insanity i hate it
i i can't help but think for you so my
my family is a family of academics like
my dad
um was uh and a fit well
he still is a physicist and was a
physics professor after he was in
industry for a long time
my brother's a professor and my uncle's
a professor um so i was always kind of
the black sheep of the family and so far
as like
you know i mean like like i
no phd or whatever it's like let's
ignore that one
uh but i feel like for your for your
boys you know growing up
uh let let's say i'm just gonna
hypothesize let's say your kids are not
like
you know really into school they're just
as uninterested
in school as i was so let's say that's
the case and that their dad
is a major entertainment figure and then
they look up and are like okay well the
school thing's not really for me
um so i i feel like they would probably
naturally gravitate towards uh creative
fields
especially i mean they're in la and the
rest of it this is just a guess
guessing and then just thinking if
you're like a creative parent
because i feel like the arc you were on
is what the arc most of us are on it
just like hey
shut up do well in school blah blah then
you have to like kind of spread your
wings to do something creative
um but in your kids case a little
different because
you actually made it as a creative and
you know you're like a
a big deal on um on tv and everything
else for them they'd be like well it's a
much more realistic aspiration for me
just to try and do what dad did than it
would be to like you know go become
a you know lawyer or uh scientist or
something
yeah i would i would it's funny they're
not
uh enamored with it i think because
they're around me and because
many of our when you're you know when
you work in a business
if you if you're a doctor you know a
bunch of doctors if you're a
plumber you know a bunch of plumbers and
if you're an actor you know a bunch of
actors and so
they come around the house but they
don't
uh so they're not enamored by what i do
they're more kind of like i don't know
it's like
slightly annoyed so i'll be interested
to see if like i've heard like eddie get
like my older son get asked and they're
like are you interested in entertainment
he's like
maybe i mean that's the sort of like i
don't know
and i don't it's it's not some sort of
like laissez faire
it's more just kind of like oh this
thing that's kind of always around
they i don't know yeah it seems like a
thing you do and
so um i i i don't know
i don't know whether they're interested
or not it's it's interesting to
think that so far they have not leapt
at um i think they would much rather
have successful youtube channels
which strikes me as the same thing
it's like i mean heck my you know my
kids actually i will
tell this story they did not give a [ __ ]
at all about my presidential run you
know maybe by design maybe not
but one of them stumbled onto a youtube
video
talking about universal basic income
that mentioned me
and then he actually came to me and was
like dad dad
you were in a youtube video i just saw
like it was like the biggest deal in the
world like i made like i made it
uh so the fact that your kids are
thinking youtube it's like that that is
their
high water mark it's like forget about e
or abc or any of that jazz it's like if
you can make it on youtube
i got i became friends with a couple
with one of the people that created
fortnite
and so we went to this fortnight
tournament and all the people that my
kids see on youtube
were there and that that was like
i think they actually looked me in the
eye and were like thank you
dad it was great they were that was the
one time i was like i did it
i was cool for two minutes amazing
yeah completely i that youtube is so you
heard it here first folks
if you're a youtuber uh that's what all
the kids want to be
so you've made it the rest of us are
just trying to make it
yeah just think if you had started when
youtube started
if you started with earnestness trying
to gain
followers and putting out videos every
week you know when it got started 20
years ago
you'd be you know you'd be michael
jackson by that
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by freshly one of the
biggest indicators of how you're going
to feel is really what you're putting in
your body
and if you're like me maybe you're not
the best in the kitchen freshly will
make you feel like you're awesome in the
kitchen because they do most of the work
for you they send it to you
you know you prepare the meal pretty
quickly gives you a sense of
accomplishment and you also get a sense
of accomplishment when you eat the food
because the food is
good for you and you can feel that so
you can take what right now
can be frankly like oh what am i going
to eat like experience
which a lot of us have during this time
and then you go and then you
prepare something that does not make you
feel good about yourself either in the
preparation or in the eating
you could like turn that experience
around pretty quick
uh we recommend it heartily the the
entire team's been using freshly
and it's been one reason why we're
feeling good so freshly is offering our
listeners 40
off for the first two orders at
freshly.com
yang that's a pretty good deal that's
freshly.com
yang join almost one and a half million
customers
who say that this is a better way to get
your meal going than whatever you're
doing right now
amen yo eat the eat the brisket it's
it's worth it
you'll thank me later freshly.com yang
[Applause]
so i know that um you've been paying
some attention to current events
uh like what what is yo i mean we we're
just this past week talking about the
passing of rpg which is a
very sad uh tragedy for for the
for the country uh for 2020
you mean the worst year ever when people
ask how we're doing
um we say 20 20 good which is like good
for this shitty year
or like you know it's like if someone
asked me how i'm doing
as long as my family's happy healthy you
say well i'm fine but things are
very gloomy i know in la you all just
had
uh the fires that ended up
polluting your air and worse for for a
number of days i had friends who said
that the sky was literally pumpkin
colored
yeah uh it was crazy and then
three nights ago a 4.5
earthquake hit about
35 miles from here and it's 11 38
at night we just got the boys down and
then it feels like
an invisible freight train goes through
the house and you can see
everything move and i was just like yep
perfect of course an earthquake
yep everything's on fire now here comes
an earthquake
and uh so it is yeah
it's 20 20. i can't wait 2021 better be
better
but yeah lose i mean with rbg uh
passing that was a real loss and
i re i can't i mean i you're a good
person to ask because they're like
they're gonna bring the vote up but then
republican senator two of them say
they're not gonna do it i don't know
i am not educated enough on
the system for right now before
just 50 days before an election whether
that could
actually it could it actually happen do
they actually
approve someone they also do have until
the new president is sworn in
technically so there's something called
the lame duck session which is between
november 3rd
of this year and let's call it january
20th of next year
so it's another you know
a couple months and change so the
the rules are that they need a majority
vote to confirm
a new justice uh right now they have
53 republican senators and like you said
two said they don't want to do it
so now you you you have if you have one
more person let's call them mitt romney
who decides not to then you'd be at 50
50
but technically the vice president can
give a tie-breaking vote
in the senate so you need two more
republican senators to join the
this is not a good idea given this late
stage
caucus if you will and we're all waiting
to see whether there are two more
senators that
that head in that direction uh there's
nothing technically stopping them from
trying to do this before the end of the
year
for me it's crazy that we're dealing
with
the repercussions that are so
predictable of
uh like of just this antiquated way of
administering the supreme court
like that the fact that and i used to
say this on the trail joel i was like
like does it make sense that we are all
literally just waiting on tenterhooks
based upon the health of an 87 year old
woman uh
and you know and then she passes which i
hate to say it was like
somewhat predictable given that you know
she's been struggling with cancer for
years and years yeah that we needed to
have in my mind like a much more modern
approach to the supreme court for a long
time
uh and i i proposed 18-year term limits
when i was running which would
improve things dramatically because then
you know you get an appointment the
person's there for 18 years which is a
plenty long time in just about any
context
but they're not going to be there until
the day they die you don't have
this political firestorm coming up out
of nowhere when someone
expires the the other big thing is
you shouldn't have only nine justices
you know which is another reason why
it's such a
firestorm whenever someone passes
because each vote is so pivotal
uh someone recommended 27
which struck me as perfectly fine and
well you just appoint a new one every
two years until you get up to that level
and then you have enough of a critical
mass you also don't need all 27 to hear
a case
that's the other thing is that in
district courts
some subset of the judges will hear it
and then if it's a major ruling that
overturns a precedent then they can
bring everyone in um so that
it's it's just painful to see our
country struggling with something based
upon
a law that was passed in 1869 and there
was an 1869 law that said
nine justices but all you need them is a
majority vote to say
you know what it's not gonna be nine
anymore like and then
you can change it because there's
nothing in the constitution about nine
so i'm all
excited about the fact that we need to
try and modernize our government that's
one of my new jams joel
modernize the government yes and the
supreme and the supreme court has
the most archaic approach you can think
of it's like
it really is like something out of a uh
game of thrones or some science fiction
novel it's like we have these nine
unelected folks that we appoint and
they're there until the day they die
and you're like checking their blood
pressure and whatnot to see like oh
you're going to be here for
for 30 or 40 years so that like
so nothing could change during that time
the whole thing
uh is just mind-blowingly
out of date i agree you know
and you've framed that perfectly because
it is you forget that when
like when scalia died it was just like
this huge surprise
and and then there's this huge you know
like
as you said it's like this gigantic
reaction because
they're appointed for life and yeah if
it was 18 years which is
a good run at any job that would you
would know
and it would be way easier i mean
there's so many
things it's so strange to think i
learned it mostly from hamilton
but uh i read the book too but uh you're
like oh they just
put these things tons of it works really
well
but there is room for improvement to
say the least my lord that that's the
unofficial motto of america now
unfortunately when it comes to
government joel it's like america don't
change anything
you know like america fixed in stone
we had this rule and it was delivered to
us on a tablet
uh no it wasn't i mean these guys
brilliant brilliant
uh people put together a system but the
system needs to
adapt and evolve uh and dc is not really
built for evolution that way
that to me is something that should be
non-partisan or bipartisan it's like
look
let's just modernize and you can imagine
a more modern approach to supreme court
terms and and appointments
you can imagine a more modern approach
to legislation and
voting yeah voting for sure i mean
the the fact that we're we're dealing
with some of like the fears we're
dealing with around voting
uh and i'm not someone like i understand
the technology and understand that look
if you just had all of our voting done
via smartphone first there's a there's a
major party that actually
likes to have people not vote which you
know that so that that's one set of
issues
but it is true that some of the
technology um
would not be ready for prime time but
you have to start moving in that
direction
and there could be a period when you
have uh
you have more advanced voting via
smartphone and then you
have some paper redundancy for a while
or whatnot you know and you can like use
things as backup
uh like that there are different
approaches you could take that it's not
just all
uh in one direction and americans would
love that stuff if
if we were like if we were like look
you're going to vote the old-fashioned
way it's cool
but we're going to do this pilot program
of
of digital voting too and we're just
going to like start
stress testing it and see how it works
and see how you like it and whatnot like
that that would be
awesome i know like that that would be
an intelligent approach instead
uh a lot of it is political where a lot
of folks
like things the way they are for
really just for keeping things the same
right now the congressional approval
rating around the country is 21 which is
very low and it's about um even with
what it's been this last number of years
it's even been lower at times been like
17.
the re-election rate for members of
congress
is 94 so think about that for a second
you're like wait a minute none of us are
happy with what's going on but
like everyone wins let's come back and
be like well if i want to keep my seat
i win and there are a bunch of
structural reasons for that
i mean part of it's gerrymandering and
the way the districts are set up
part of it though is just this massive
fundraising advantage
where the average successful house
candidate raised 1.6 million for
senate it's 10.4 million and so hey can
you imagine
a normal person trying to raise 1.6
million for a congressional campaign
be impossible it's like you know like
like i mean i was frankly something of
an unknown
um but i remember raising that first uh
set of money and it was brutal
like no one wanted to give i give
anybody either i was like hey you and i
have been offense for a long time i'm
running for president you want to donate
20
uh 700 my campaign and that that stuff
was really really difficult
so for anyone who is trying to do the
right thing and uh you know
run for congress for their district like
unless you have been
cultivating tons of relationships with
people that have money over a period of
time
like you're not going to be able to
raise another to be competitive and
frankly if you were the sort of person
that was cultivating those relationships
for a long time
you probably are not the person we're
hoping runs
like those two things are kind of
mutually yeah they have no choice but to
cultivate those relationships
because they're not going to raise the
money if they don't and it's so
you know like camp the campaigning is
endless it starts
so it's it makes you know like
buying it's like buying christmas gifts
in july
and i like the uh european mail i guess
it's british where they're like okay you
can come
start campaigning on this day and then
yes for it and then it stops
and and but the system is so
ingrained and it help you know it's
helped a lot of
people and so they're not going to stop
it the never-ending campaign man i just
saw this stat that said um
like barack obama and his last year in
office when he
like uh or one of the years he was
running for reelection it might have
been 2012.
attended over 200 fundraisers that year
and and you're just like how are you
trying to run the country right
and show up to 200 fundraisers does
anyone think that's like an optimal use
of this
or freaking trump has never stopped
campaigning and then you think about the
senate and then you think about congress
and
obviously the state congress all of that
and they're all doing it
and i just like i don't know what if you
were
would you want your doctor uh if your
doctor had to raise their salary
you know like no no i want them to focus
on medicine
and making sure that i stay healthy and
they're up to date with the latest
information and
not out doing this work to
you know just maintain them themselves
and
it just is and i think we so much of it
we take for granted
and we just feel like well that's how it
is people start these debates
a year before that anybody and it's just
like you gotta be kidding me it goes
on and on and then i stop listening then
i'm just like okay
i all of a sudden it becomes like major
league baseball where there's 169 or 165
regular season games i'm like
i'll start paying attention i don't know
90
games in 110 games playoffs
definitely that's fun but or just like
it's
endless so yes it is endless
there was a study that said the average
member of congress spends between 30 and
70 percent of their time
fundraising because if you're a member
of congress
let's say i i won this election in
november 2020 and i show up
i'm up for re-election again in two
years
uh you know and so let you pretty much
start spending
raising money immediately to try and uh
build your own moat to defend your seat
uh and then even if let's say
hypothetically you were confident you
were going to win and you'd raise enough
money
the party wants you to raise more money
anyway to give to other races and to
give to the party and that's how they
end up doling out
some of the committee seats and the rest
of it so there's really no limit
like like no one can have raised enough
because if you raise enough for your
seat you're supposed to raise for the
party for other
uh folks and and then you end up
having this favor trading system it's
one reason why nancy pelosi is the
speaker of the house because
she's from san francisco which is a very
affluent area and
she was chief fundraiser she was like
the lead fundraiser for a long time
uh and so then she has rose through the
ranks because she'd done everyone so
many favors because she had
just money coming out of her ears
throughout the district
and so then if you're like an incoming
member of congress you're like looking
up at this freaking
giant totem pole of money
and you're like how am i gonna climb the
money totem pole
and then you end up spending all your
time fundraising and then we wonder why
nothing's getting done i mean right now
the fact that there's no stimulus bill
passed is an embarrassment uh and
like an another tragedy and
it got so bad joel that like 40 members
of congress
uh just came up and said like hey look
here's a compromise bill 40 of us are
for it like it's somewhere between
these two extremes uh and and even that
i mean you know things are bad
when 40 members of congress were like
look enough is enough let's just
freaking like
like present a compromise bill that we
think uh will
uh get support and and then that that
also has gone nowhere i mean
i'm i'm getting increasingly fed up with
yeah that's when i want to
drag one like all right if someone get
in my car i'll drag you into my car
let's just take a drive around uh like a
decent part of the city and you will see
how many businesses are just gone and
they're like you don't i i keep thinking
i mean this is i know it gets said over
and over but i was like
if you give us if you get them this is
what this every conservative
economist and liberal economist they all
agree there needs to be stimulus
because the hotels and bars and movie
theaters are
all gonna go and everyone just thinks
well
it's not or something because and then
the recovery will be
that much harder and we keep we'll just
keep [ __ ] ourselves
thank you i'm joel mchale you know you
know joel it's making me think
i i'm curious how many members of
congress are dyslexic
uh because i feel like if you had more
dyslexic members of congress they'd be
like oh how do we get something done
let's go let's go do this i i feel like
there's like a need for that where right
now there's this strange group think
where
things that don't make sense are
presented as if they do make sense and
then
if you had someone who was an
independent thinker they'd come to be
like this really does not make any sense
that
they should just lock them in there
they're like here's some food and water
don't show up in a suit and tie you each
can you can all wear sweatsuits and
you've got to work it out
no matter what and if i don't know and
then if
i don't i don't know what the then we
start i don't then we start cutting off
a pinky or something but uh
but it was like you gotta you can't this
is for it's
yeah i now i sound like every single
person on television but that stimulus
is so important because when we come out
on the other side of this thing which is
probably
not going to be for a while this is good
it's just decimating my friend
he owns this great burger place castles
burgers downtown
and i'm like how you guys doing they're
like oh we're doing pretty good actually
except the hotel we're in is about to
close which means we close
i'm like ugh there's no reason for it
we have such a rich country we could
afford to float
the country and then that will be that
much
oh my gosh so crazy again
you're right it's common sense uh
something like 80 percent of americans
want cash relief during the pandemic
uh and the the thing that has hit me
joel is that
i used to think that if you had enough
people on board with something then that
would get the job done
but now i'm realizing that our
government is increasingly detached from
what it is that we all want uh and i've
been
digging into some of the structural
reasons why that is so part of it is
this 21
satisfaction rate 94 re-election rate
you're like well
that's a pretty big divide like if i was
uh
let's say running a company i'd be like
this might not be introducing the
feedback
[Laughter]
that i'm looking for uh but it
because our government like you said
people just have just
thought okay this is the way it is so it
sho so it was so it ever shall be
uh and so now now for me it really is
about the systems it's like
okay how do our elected representatives
get elected how do they keep getting
reelected
what are their incentives how does the
leadership work
this is the this is a gridlock that's
happened over and over
on a thousand different things uh and i
mean
obviously going back a few
administrations and where they just were
like
we're just not gonna do any we're just
not gonna help you at all
how what's the salute how would you
change that system
so that would stop all right here are
a few big things that we need to do
number one
is public campaign financing so that if
you run and you get a certain number of
signatures you get some public money
enough to be competitive uh my proposal
during the campaign was 100 democracy
dollars for every voter you can give to
any candidate you want and so then if
i got 10 000 people behind me i get a
million bucks and that's enough for me
to
to compete and run wash out some of the
corporate money
uh because right now just the companies
are
bombing hundreds of millions of dollars
into various campaigns so that's that's
big
domino number one number two is
uh open primaries in place of these
party primaries
and trying to make the districts more
competitive
so right now over 80 percent of the
congressional districts are either clean
republican or clean democrat
in other words there's no there's no
uncertainty as to who's going to win the
general election
and so if you're a member of congress in
one of these
safe seats then you don't care about
compromising with the other side you
just care about not getting primaried by
someone in your own party
typically someone much more extreme and
so that ends up distorting your
legislative
incentives because it's like well i'd
rather just seem like
i'm like very very strong on this side
and if nothing gets done
like i'm safe but if i were to reach
across the aisle
and compromise and do something that
some people are unhappy with that's
actually very bad for me
in terms of my re-election prospects
that that's the current set of
incentives that they have
um so if you had open primaries instead
of the closed primary system
then you'd have to reach out to more
people in your district and not just
satisfy the folks in your party
the big change in in this direction that
would be huge is
ranked choice voting because then if you
have
a number of people
in the district and it's open and
ranked choice voting then makes it so
that no one's worried about wasting
their vote
for number one because right now it's
like oh you can't vote for that person
you're going to end up
costing us this election if you have
ranked choice voting you can vote for
whoever the heck you want and then
trust that your your vote's going to end
up
counted in the best way possible uh
and it also diminishes the incentives to
campaign negatively
because if you're if let's say there are
five of you in the field and i trash
candidate number two then that person
looks bad i look bad and then candidate
number three is going to come up and
peter's both
so at right choice voting elections
everyone plays it
more above board because when you start
throwing rocks at people like you know
you look bad and the person you're
throwing rocks at
looks bad so so these would be the the
biggest changes you could make
but the the change that i think has been
rattling around for a long time that i
am totally for that would change this
um maybe the most dramatically is just
term limits for members of congress
where if you have a term it's a little
bit like
term uh 18-year terms for supreme court
justices
but we're making almost the equivalent
of lifetime appointments in congress
right now
where you have dozens of members of
congress who've been there for 30 or 40
years
uh you know like and you can see it too
in the age of our
leadership where not to knock you know
because they're a lot of
like awesome um people of any generation
in any stage
but we have the equivalent of a
geritocracy right now
which is one reason why things feel the
way that they do i mean the average age
of a us senator i believe is 62.
if you look at leadership uh nancy
pelosi steny hoyer mitch mcconnell
are all in their 70s or even 80s i
believe in one case
uh so you we we have a system that is
rewarding
seniority to the nth degree in congress
and nothing ever changes so i would have
term limits for members of congress and
what's wild joel is when i looked into
this it turns out the vast majority of
americans intuitively agree with
with term limits like it has something
like a 78 or 80
approval rating so think about that for
a second like what can you get 80
of americans to agree on like not a
whole lot but you can get them to agree
on the fact that
good that's something they would all
agree on i like chocolate i mean yeah
about 80 yeah it's like i like chocolate
and if i send someone to dc they should
eventually come back
[Laughter]
about the only two things i could agree
on how do you get them to vote on
something that would limit them
that's literally so counter-intuitive
well my my big proposal joel is
term limits for members of congress but
current
current members are exempt or
grandfathered in so
if you're a current legislator you might
get on board with this because you're
like well
like doesn't affect me
[Laughter]
and it turns out strom thurman was
actually still alive and he was like
it's fine with me i'm 125 now and
yeah how long did he lack he was like
when he was 94.
something like that yeah he he got up
there
uh so those are some of the big
structural fixes if there's something
that i'm excited about right now that's
sweeping the nation it is
ranked towards voting because some
states are voting on it right now
um i think massachusetts is going to
pass it maine already has it
um i think seattle and new york city
have it too not statewide but
but in the cities so when voters find
out about rank choice voting they love
it they get excited
because everyone realizes it's just a
better expression of preference
and it's a better democracy it's just a
higher functioning democracy
if you can just say look i like this
person first this person second this
person third and then after that i
refuse to even express a preference
because i hate everyone else like that's
fine
you know like that that would that would
work that would have worked wonders
um over the last number of uh
presidential cycles too to be honest
with you because
if you look at what was going on in the
republican primary in 2016
uh trump was trump won those
primaries but he wasn't getting 50 in a
lot of the places
you know that there were a lot of places
early on whereas like trump
with hit with his crowd but then there
were you know whatever six
or seven other candidates and they were
splitting up the rest if you had ranked
choice voting
it might be that someone else would have
emerged on top
yeah no i don't and it's one of those
things when you say it you're like yeah
why
isn't it it seems so it's such a seems
so logical
isn't like yeah well that's that seems
like such a
well that's what you do if you you if
you're in a boat
you need an ore because that makes you
move like right that seems
perfectly reasonable and it doesn't seem
that complicated at all
yeah it's not when people find out about
rank choice voting
um it ends up winning everything because
everyone looks at him he's like well
that just seems better that's more
logical like we should just do that
uh and right now the the only resistance
is from frankly uh folks who are
currently
in power who like the 94 re-election
rate who are like oh no
like this is going to complicate my life
like i've got my
million dollar moat all set up i could
just like i could just
crouch here forever in the current
system um so
uh but the average voter loves it and if
we can get that done for anyone who
wants a more vibrant democracy or is
thinking that there's a need for a third
party
in the united states of america or other
major parties because the current
two-party system might not be
humming uh then you should just get
behind rank choice voting because the
great thing about is it's non-partisan
bipartisan it's like looks just better
process better democracy
but it ends up enabling uh
more dynamic uh third-party candidates
as well because then the third-party
candidate can show up and be like
don't worry you're not going to help
that person you hate get elected or like
you're not going to be wasting your vote
and you can still vote for me
and like people because right now that
that argument actually is very very
powerful
on people it's like no one wants to help
you know the person they like the least
get
elected massachusetts seattle new york
have it
massachusetts is voting on it right now
maine has it
and then new york and seattle i believe
just recently adopted it or are voting
on it right
yeah and they gotta get rid of you know
the the college
you know the uh what do you call it the
uh electoral college yeah that is
i i this is why i feel right about this
is because even when i was six years old
and they were explaining government to
me and i was just like
what i'm so confused why is it called a
college
a b uh what is the point of it and
i couldn't i still to this day are like
so we
and and it doesn't make any sense at all
and i get
that it has benefited both parties it
has benefited the republican party most
recently
uh with like bush gore and obviously
trump uh
clinton but it's benefited the democrats
at some point
but i still to this day it's just like
the popular vote seems
as simple occam's razor that is
the straightest thing lying to electing
the most popular person
so here's my proposal for the electoral
college reform that i think would make
everyone happy
so the one problem with trying to
abolish it is that you need a
constitutional
uh amendment super majority to do it and
you'd have
a dozen states that are like wait a
minute i'm less influential under
you know the popular vote system because
i'm nebraska montana like you know like
the electoral college helps me
so so then you so you run into a very
very practical problem where it's like
i'll never get this changed because
there are a lot of people i'll be
shooting themselves in the foot
um there's a there's a legitimate reason
to which which is that
let's say we had popular vote and i was
running for president which i did thank
you everyone who supported me
really appreciate it yeah then
i i would never leave a major media
market i would always be in a major
media market because i'll just get more
votes
yeah and then if i went if i went to
some less populated area it'd just be a
waste of time
now right now like the balance might be
excessive in a particular direction but
you know i don't i'm not sure it'd be
optimal for us just to be
uh campaigning on the coast or in the
big cities so the the change that would
that's practical and doable that most
everyone should get behind that would
also help
ease this problem is you make it so that
the electoral college
awards its votes not win or take all by
state
but proportionally by state so in other
words uh if
you know if california has 40 uh
electoral votes or more
then they get awarded proportional to
how many how much i won that state by so
instead of getting all of them i'd get
60 of them or something along those
lines and if you did that then all of a
sudden the incentives for
national candidates would be to campaign
anywhere they can actually move the
margin
instead of just campaigning in ohio
michigan
florida um you know north carolina
arizona like wisconsin like the handful
of swing states
it's funny joel because i was in iowa a
lot because i was running for president
um and it was wall-to-wall campaign ads
you know you turned on the tv i'd get to
the hotel i turned on that tv and it was
like
bloomberg elizabeth warren
uh me sometimes which is really
entertaining being a hotel room the
senior presidential ad pop up and be
like oh i remember shooting that nice
work team that was good
uh and then if if you could go to
another media market it's like zero
because you know no one cares about like
i grew up i grew from washington state
where nobody
ever came to because they knew that it
was always gonna be blue
so no one ever showed up it's great
so this is a reform that most states
could get behind because they're like
hey i'd like some love i'd like some
attention why are you always just like
throwing
[ __ ] at florida all like all the time
like you know like give some love
this way and it it ends up creating a
a more fair system so that you know if
you did win the popular vote under the
system that
um that i'm describing like the odds of
your winning the electoral college too
would be
quite high because you'd get like the
proportional so it lines them up
somewhat but it also makes it so that no
state is losing
the way that they would lose if you were
to abolish the electoral college
entirely
um it might it would actually make some
of the non-swing states
uh be more important for political
considerations
[Music]
if you are listening to this you like
podcasts and you're thinking what
podcast is gonna
entertain me but also give me some
actual knowledge i can use
and one pad podcast we recommend hardly
that does just that is the jordan
harbinger show on apple podcast spotify
wherever you listen to podcasts wherever
you got this one
jordan's a really smart guy himself but
he brings on
experts and technicians who do
incredible things from frankly talking
people out of their money
[Laughter]
to safe cracking to spy
craft he's a bit of a guy so he kind of
talks to people that you know you'd be
interested in hearing from
um who've done some james bond type
stuff so if you are
intrigued by how to bring some james
bond into your life
go to the jordan harbinger show we enjoy
the show
think you will too that's h-a-r-b
as in boy i-n-g-e-r
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Applause]
i really need to go to your uh i don't
know your
retreat or subscribe to your newsletter
because i
learning a lot and no but that makes
perfect sense proportional to what they
state is actually what people are
actually saying would that would
make a candidate go have to campaign
everywhere and uh or you that which
again now you'd be even more stressed
out because you'd be spending
another two years on the road while
you're 50 state strategy
right joel i didn't get enough visiting
just those uh those early primary states
i missed out
idaho coming your way look at your
background did you
major in political science or you
i studied economics and political
science then i went to law school which
in my case
like was maybe not the best choice um
but i you know i have spent some time
um in the process too i learned a lot by
running to
because the the entrepreneurial process
we were talking about before
like i was a startup guide entrepreneur
decided that
the you invented was you invented the
scrunchie or spanx
i can't definitely not spanx because
sarah blakely
is much more successful than i am i'm
wearing them now
that's why you look so sharp joel uh but
it it was
like another startup where you show up
and you're like okay like what are the
rules
what do i have to do uh so i i figured
out so there were only two rules for
running for president so you could
definitely do it joel
uh it's 35 years or older uh
and natural born citizen so it's like
check and check and i'm not a
natural-born citizen
oh [ __ ] i didn't know that you're out i
was born in rome
italy and uh to an american into a
canadian so
i'm out i think you still might might be
in uh because i
could well because i think like ted cruz
got was born in canada or something and
like you know
didn't keep him from running um so that
there was there's something up
like natural born citizen doesn't mean
like uh like greek myth
48 state type thing i i don't know like
we'd have to
dig into your your actual uh you know
circumstances
what's the other natural born citizen
and the other rule is you have to
35 years and older 35 years old shirt
and shoes and
pants but uh yeah well okay
well then i'll i'll be your running mate
let's do it so yeah
yang mchale in the the tagline would be
not the darkest timeline
yang mchale not the darkest timeline
yeah
and i'll be like eat it ken and then
every once in a while for campaign
events ken would swap in for me
[Laughter]
wait that seems slightly racist
yeah it's okay if i say it though
thank you so those are only two rules
and so it it turns out that
um all of the rules we think of were
primarily
uh just things the media agreed on
at various points where and even this
cycle
um so most americans probably heard of
approximately let's call it 24
candidates 24 would be if you were
paying close attention
i take that back most americans have
probably heard of approximately
10 candidates
but the reality was that hundreds of
people
filed to run for president this time you
just never heard of most of them
and i actually went digging just for fun
where i like saw the people
and some of them were joke filings uh
some of them were like the dark lord or
like whoever
you know i mean so they're pretty funny
like you know if anyone takes
inspiration from this it is like i could
run some like funny
uh presidential account campaign um when
i filed as an example like it got
absolutely zero notice because it's just
like andrew young is running for
president it's like who gives a [ __ ]
like
no one knows who that was because it's
like november 2017. um
so the rules around filing are very very
loose
where there's really no restriction on
who can run
the the problem then is generating any
real
resources or attention for your campaign
and obviously the vast majority of these
hundreds of people that filed
don't raise a dime no one's ever heard
of them they filed as a joke
there were people that actually went out
there and said i'm running for president
like i want to give everyone money
and the robots are coming etc like that
i mean that's obviously
describes a particular candidate uh and
so
um so it's interesting joel to reflect
upon the fact that
uh you know my candidacy ended up
raising tens of millions and like i got
a lot of
attention and i became a contender uh
and
in a way it's only now looking at it
that i appreciate
um just how uh
how much that took like like looking at
the hundreds of people that filed
anonymously
that disappeared um so the the rules are
primarily social
is what i'm suggesting that the actual
rules just about anyone can satisfy but
the the real rules
are the institutional rules the media
rules
the dnc's rules in this case uh and so
the dnc
this was another entrepreneurship thing
the dnc set rules up to make the debates
and then i was like
what's the rule what's the rules like 65
000 donations
all right let's go do that let's go do
that like it was it was a lot of fun on
that level as a campaign because they
would
like set up a bar for you and then you
were like let's go get it
and would the democrat like who's ever
in charge they'd be like
well you did good on that okay good now
if you do the
next one you get a star on your
briefcase so go ahead i mean
when did they finally start noticing you
when you're like oh this guy's actually
not messing around and he's gonna do
something when did that
would someone call you and be like all
right
good news you're you're you're in you're
you've
you've done enough so far we did have
a line of communication going with the
dnc
uh during the campaign and you know it
was i'd say cordial
uh what was that is the word i'd use but
was funny joel
is that um they were setting the lines
up
relatively late in the day or like the
bars that you have to
clear and so someone like there was a
point in a campaign where
they were trying to figure out what the
debate threshold was going to be for
what like this is pretty late in the day
um like maybe the ninth debate or what
like one of the early state debates
um and then someone asked me what i
thought the threshold was going to be
and i said whatever tulsi has plus two
or something like that because they they
they legitimately would look at the
field and be like who do i wanted to
stick to or not wanted this thing it'd
be like let's just turn the dial
to here um but the but the funny thing
about it for me was that i was passing
people
that we knew they wanted in the debate
um so as long as i did that it was like
the old joke about like you know i don't
need to outrun
the bear i just need to run the person
next to me
like as long as i was outrunning someone
that i knew they wanted to keep then
like i i was gonna be all right
that's so funny that's such a great
analogy to describe that because it is
weird for
us at home where they're like here's the
here's like the here's the varsity uh
and then here's jv oh that jv guy
he got up to varsity and then that one
varsity guy he's down to
freshman basketball and so that's
that it's it's a weird thing just
because i'm like i don't because you
take it for granted when this way when
it's all being worked out
and yeah i can't imagine the effort
well thank you again everyone who made
it happen but i benefited tremendously
from these rules joel
there were some candidates that were
hurt by them grievously
uh because if it because if you were not
able to make that stage then all of a
sudden everyone
treated you like you had zero chance to
win in zero
business running and so some of the
candidates that got left in the cold
by that were i'm gonna call out steve
bullock the governor of montana he got
in late
and he got in laid in part because he
was trying to pass some legislation in
montana so he was doing his job
and you know you got to give him credit
for doing his job then he showed up late
and then he didn't make i think he was
the third debate and then
after that he was it was he was done for
more or less
because at that point you can't get
critical mass because like everyone's
like well you weren't in that debate and
they just use the debate as like the
filter so i benefited tremendously
because i kept making them
and they they got raised in the barn
like the team was like all right what do
we got to do what have we got to do it
was uh
it was it was great fun um but
that so whatever and you know there were
some candidates that were left out in
the cold by it though that
you know i i think deserved um
deserved a better look frankly from the
american people and that was one of the
fun things joel too about running is
that i would actually hang out with all
these people individually because like
you know you're in iowa new hampshire
you just see them hang out with them and
and so
you get a sense of them kind of the way
you and i like you know just have this
conversation like you get a sense of
someone
uh and then you see something in the
media and it's totally different than
what you thought
like the reality was because you're like
i was just with that person like they
were
fine or i really like them like
that person was awesome and then they
get treated like uh
like a joke sometimes you're like i
actually thought that person was
terrific
um so it it was funny having that
that set of experiences yeah how often
would you find that
that would be the case where oh they
seem perfectly normal
or great and cool and intelligent cool
and then
i guess it's not an immediate perception
but like oh they're doing something
horrible they're they're passing
something terror like they've done this
terrible thing
like in their state or something does
that happen a lot
not seeing like a crime but just like oh
yeah you don't wanna
you don't wanna deal with them uh and
then they get you away from them
yeah it did happen joel on i i wrote
something where i talked about
in particular the media treatment of
marianne williamson and joe sestak
and um joe sestak is like a real-life
captain america figure
he was like the aircraft he was the
commander
of like a naval um aircraft carrier
group
which is thousands and thousands of
people and lives
uh i believe he has a phd from harvard
graduated maybe third in his class in
the naval academy
he's like a superman um he was two-term
congressman from pennsylvania
he at one point because he was so
um like uh in need of attention he
walked across the state of new hampshire
as during the primary just to like meet
people and try and get attention
because the media was just ignoring him
completely and when when i met him i was
like this guy's awesome this guy's great
like you you can see how he commanded
thousands and thousands of soldiers and
it's just like
like he'd be a better president than uh
a significant number of other people
that are
running for sure and the media just
would not give him the time of day at
all
and when they did talk about him they
treated him like a joke they'd be like
what
what's why why is this man running kind
of thing i was like well maybe because
he's a patriot and an
ass kicker was what i always thought
like whenever i saw
those stories uh so so that was one
thing where i was just like man like the
the uh depiction does not line up with
my sense of
who those people are uh wonder
why do you think that you were able to
push through so
effectively and someone like that has to
run across a state
oh i think that i was very much of the
moment
joel and certainly i'd love to hear from
you like how you ended up
encountering me in my campaign but uh
there was a period of time when
it seemed like the media presented me as
like the internet candidate
like i think that i was a very uh
modern candidate in a way that someone
like joe
was more a candidate of like a you know
frankly like a
more establishment-friendly time um i i
think right now there are many americans
who don't think our institutions
are functioning that well and they were
completely open to
the new entrepreneurial type who had a
different message and a different
approach
and i used a medium to communicate that
one of the things i said
to folks is i would never have gone
anywhere not for podcasts
you know there was a long period of time
when cable news was kind of ignoring me
and then i would go on
um i would go on sam harris's podcast or
i'd go
on i mean obviously joe rogan was
enormous
and that was through sam so you know i
owe sam like a great debt
um so i came up via podcasts
and 21st century media and i think that
is one of the reasons why i got that
critical mass and momentum
and some of the other candidates didn't
i noticed you
i remember noticing it because okay i
think it was during a debate
when elizabeth warren asked everyone on
stage to pledge
that they would
it was either tax like they would just
take ten percent like all
it was either that they have make all
the billionaires just give
a huge amount of their money i if i'm
wrong and then there's a wealth tax
yeah well tax you were like the first
they were like what do you think you're
like
no they tried that in northern europe it
didn't work
and that was the first i was like oh
this
is i was very i was like oh i can't wait
to hear
and then you explained it so well and i
was like yeah that makes sense
that that was that was a really amazing
moment
thank you joel for remembering that that
that's those were yeah the debates were
really a great catalyst for for me in
the campaign because
you and other families around the
country were like who's that guy he said
something i kind of like let me look
that up
like my campaign every time would tell
me what like the google search results
or the web traffic results were
um after each debate uh so i was you
know going for those numbers honestly
um like the the big traffic spike we saw
was when we gave money away that one
time
we were like we're gonna give 10
families a thousand bucks a month just
because like that's actually a better
move than anything um
anything else and and i got off the
stage and they were like
you know you would not believe like we
apparently got like millions of hits
like uh immediately after i said those
words
you have to do is give away huge amounts
of money
it was like and and the press freaking
derided
that move on the debate stage as like a
gimmick
and and whatnot like they lambasted me
uh for
days afterwards uh anyone who evaluated
the debate was like biggest loser like
andrew yang or whatever and then i was
like
then i was like well i thought the goal
was to actually
win this thing like i
i think like people actually you know
becoming curious about me enough to go
to the website sort of like an important
step towards like getting people
interested and winning
um so so that there was like a sort of
strange
uh kind of rules of the road that uh you
know anytime i violated or even when i
didn't wear a tie freaking
you know some journalists freaked out
the first time and then eventually that
got normal
about all those stupid little things and
you're like
yeah god forbid you don't wear a tie
oh my lord imagine the first dude
because i say dude because women weren't
allowed but like didn't wear
like a wig you know one of those dumb
wigs they must have been like what are
you doing what is what just okay you
think you're at home okay i just want to
wear the wig
you know the uh the 1776 wig or whatever
oh yeah well that was the that was the
end of the wig's party
joel the wigs i'm gonna start it up
again
that would be great we should go old
school the new party should be
the wigs and then everyone just wear one
of those old school 1776 like
uh gray hair wigs would be badass it
would be so great
[Music]
and also the rules you had to smell as
bad as they did back then
because they must i mean think about
when they were like
in those government in those buildings
with no air conditioning and they're all
wearing wigs and covered in wool it must
have
just they must have gotten so much done
because it smelled
so bad and they just like pass it we
gotta get out of here and get some fresh
air
yet another innovation from the mind of
joel mchale
it's like trap them in the room poor
hygiene
turn up the heat turn up the heat and
then yeah and no deodorant
and then they'll get they'll pass
everything in a second
great well thank you for doing this joel
uh do you have anything you're working
on um right now that that you want folks
to
see well card sharks comes out on the
18th of october
i'll be i might be appearing on math
singer i'm not sure if i can
tell that i'm on ken's new show um
i can see your voice and i'm on a
dc show called um star girl where i play
star man and uh so that looks like
that's going to be coming back and
you know in the meantime i got to do a
voiceover for the nfl last night and
i've never been happier in my life
so uh i i basically got to introduce the
patriots seahawks game
through a voiceover and i was just i was
like a boyhood dream come true
well keep an eye out for joel mchale and
his voice can we do a podcast where i
host it and i just asked you questions
the whole time yeah of course
you know i'll bounce back and and do
that man i am an able both host and
guest
andrew yang versatile oh no
no because whenever you talk i'm always
like i hadn't thought about it that way
and
absolutely and so that's that's
i i swear i'm just i'm yeah it's like uh
how it used to be uh back in greek
greece where
socrates the students would just ask the
questions the whole time instead of
socrates going like here's what we're
gonna learn you're like no no just start
asking questions and you're gonna you're
gonna know everything after that
i love it brother well i'll i'll let you
uh go be a dad thank you for doing this
and uh let's
keep trying to uplift people and make
good things happen for 2020. this
terrible year is going to end
and then 2021 will hopefully be a whole
new page for all of us
yes from your lips to god's ears
yeah you are i am such a big fan of your
huge brain and heart
oh thank you brother appreciate the heck
out of you we you know we
all just need to head out and head in a
better direction
thanks for doing this joel all the best
of the family thanks man
great to talk to you thank you thank you
thank you for having me
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you